good morning believe nation today's
message is it's okay to be unhappy over
do you grab this you said I'm not a big
proponent of happiness no I think it's
overrated
ya know what is that I'm not talking
about a peace I'm talking about
happiness because there's such an
emphasis on that we gotta be happy all
the time you're not happy this I know
though it's not to be happy as okay is
what you said you gotta have it you got
to have the other to appreciate any kind
of happiness or to understand any kind
of happiness I'm yeah I'm it's overrated
so what do you think well to be honest I
kind of agree with them a little bit but
I must have disagree with them I mean I
feel like yeah you definitely need to
have a sense of what unhappiness is to
appreciate happiness but I think you
know aiming for happiness is one of the
best things to aim for because we're all
emotional creatures and without
happiness we are not motivated so if
you're doing something that you're not
happy about why do it anyway like if
it's for success and it's not making you
happy then you're doing for other people
in a sense and I feel like that's that's
not that's not something that I want to
push done I don't know what other people
but I think happiness is one of the most
if not the most important thing that you
shoot up you should pursue cool when I
play this clip alex is here in the
background like yes you got to put that
one on
so we're doing a few Alex so this is
actually one for me one agree in that to
really understand how case you have to
know the other side and so if you would
really want to be appreciative for what
you have when it's not there then it's
easier to be appreciative right you need
you need to have the reins appreciate
the Sun I don't think that happiness is
overrated I think that's part of what
you're saying I think if you are unhappy
you want to try to make your best effort
to try to get happy I think if you are
doing too many things that you look at
yourself in the mirror every day and
you're just unhappy then then something
needs a change like in when in my life
if something if I'm stressed out if I'm
doing too much if I'm not happy with
something and I if that's for too many
days in a row then I change something on
my schedule to try to get happy again
it's understand that happy that that
being sad is normal too like it's okay
to feel sad I think that's part of much
is what he's trying to say like if
something happens in your life and you
know your dog gets hit by a car there's
a death in the family that's okay to be
sad you know that's natural that's
normal you can't try to get out of that
too quickly can also be detrimental
right like oh I don't care that she died
I'm gonna go and do this thing right
like that's that that's gonna mess you
up right like there's mourning periods
and so you don't listen want to rush
through that too quickly but I think as
a general way of living to pursue things
that make you happy is is good at least
in my view I'm generally a happy person
I try to do things that make me more
happy if my schedule gets out of whack I
try to correct it to keep back on my
happy path and the next extension is I
want other people to be happy as well
like I'm trying to create happiness for
others for you guys watching the videos
for Arya who's joining us here on the
channel right so hey come on and join me
for the videos for the people around me
like I want to create an aura of
happiness for people to stretch
themselves and I want to have an impact
on others and so those are my thoughts
so the question the day today is what do
you think about happiness you guys rat
or your
what do you think what happiness we're
going to start at the big war leave it
in the comments below which on the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shut up and press